[Music]
afternoon everyone my name is Jorden to
Gani I'm a software engineer on bigquery
I was one of the original bigquery
engineers have been working on it for a
long time wrote a book about it I'm
managing part of the team now but it
hasn't been so long that I've been
managing as I have forgotten how
everything works a couple of
prerequisites this is a highly technical
talk if you're not here to hear a
technical talk then you might not be
might not be for you I'm not going to
give any any pitches or sales or
marketing stuff I'm just going to talk
about technology the only the only pitch
you'll hear will be I'm going to try to
convince you that we have some pretty
cool technology and bigquery so the
problem that I'm trying to solve with
this talk is is really to to solve this
anti pattern that we see a lot which is
we get a customer they start using
bigquery everything's working great
their queries are super fast they're
happy and then they find that they hit a
roadblock they have hit something that
runs slowly it doesn't run at all and
they don't know how to fix it and
because the bigquery architecture is is
so different than what they've used to
they don't have a lot of options so they
either post on Stack Overflow they email
support or you know now that we're
selling to enterprises a lot of the
enterprise people have had the phone
numbers of Google VPS and so and so we
get nasty emails that have to be solved
really quickly can anybody guess which
one of these is most effective in
getting their problem solved
yeah Stack Overflow is is usually gonna
usually going to work actually not our
support folks are really good as well
but the it's nice to have like a Stack
Overflow we have a community of people
that that are that are quite helpful and
often you know work they work for free
and very helpful so I'm gonna walk
through some
it's a big query query plans and show
you how those query plans map to the
architecture and I'm going to go into
the architecture and kind of try to give
you an idea of a mental model so you can
develop an intuition about about what's
going to work what's not going to work
this you know this talk is called
advance big query the it's I'm not going
to show a whole lot of advanced big
query features I'm just gonna try to
show and advance like how in advance big
query user would use bigquery to start
out I'm gonna review a little bit the
architecture of a dremel which is the
query engine that the bigquery uses and
this picture might look a little
different if you've read the the Dremel
paper things have changed in the last
couple years it's no longer a static
tree but we have a dynamic tree that can
sort of assemble different stages as as
needed and I'll show a lot more of that
in in a minute
and then you know but as always we read
from columnar columnar store super fast
Colossus datastore highly distributed
it's one of the sort of the keys from
our to our to our success so let's go
through a simple query execution do a
filter and an account aggregation so how
does this work
Stage one we can apply the filter we can
do partial counts in parallel stage two
then we can compute the sum of those
partial counts you'll see there's some
slot numbers over here I'll describe
what those what those mean and where we
get them in a second so this is what the
query plan looks like for that for that
query and this you can find this in the
bigquery UI I'll show I'll show you in
in in a couple minutes
it's you know you can see the query plan
from from your queries but there's a lot
of information here so I'm gonna go over
it relatively relatively slowly so so it
makes it clear so here we have basically
which part of the query is running at
each at each stage they may look a
little different than the query text
erode because this is what it looks like
to our to our query engine so here we're
doing we're reading from the underlying
table and we're applying the filter
and actually we you know for this kind
of filter we can actually push that into
the storage into the storage layer to
get a much much faster query performance
but then we're also doing the
aggregation of the count star in this at
this level and and writing that to the
next to the next stage so the next stage
we read from the the previous stage
output we compute the sum of the partial
counts and we return the to the total
sum then there's these four timing
windows here the first one is weight
though and the weight time in this one
is not particularly large because we
didn't actually have to wait for
anything one thing to note note is that
this only starts when that stage starts
running so you can see in the second
stage the stage two started running at
the same time stage one did because as
soon as it gets partial output it can
start aggregating the the results in
general these these have three different
colors or three different gradations
there's kind of the faintest one which
means
didn't really do anything there's the
darkest one which is the average time
and then there's the little less dark
one which is the the max time so since
we're running these things in parallel
we have lots of parallel workers this is
sort of how we represent the the the
parallelism in this case read didn't do
much this is reading from IO or this was
not a significant bottleneck the compute
stage is a little more interesting here
the compute stage the medium the average
time is actually where we where we spent
most of the time and the the the max
time wasn't much higher so this is
actually a pretty healthy query or a
pretty healthy pattern because we didn't
have a lot of longtail effects and
rights was fairly minimal okay so the
next bit of information that we have is
the input and output sizes the in this
query we read over a billion rows and we
output 220 rows can anybody guess what
this two
20 number means so this is the available
parallelism this is actually how many
parallel machines were running because
each one of these things is doing a
parallel count and each one outputs one
row so we can kind of see by using these
query plans how many how much how many
resources bigquery is is is throwing at
the problem and because because the wait
time is low none of these had - none of
these had to wait for for to be
scheduled we can actually know that this
is how many how much how many resources
were actually used during the query the
the next stage then reads those 220 rows
and and outputs just the single one so a
lot of data just on one on one slide
hopefully it'll make the the next ones
go go more smoothly if you look at the
if we increase the the the size that
we're of the tables that we're querying
over we can look at what happens to the
query plans so this is the quarry plan
for the same query but just running over
a data set that's ten times as large so
we can see this is 10 billion rows it
outputs two thousand rows and then one
interesting difference here is the
though you know while the commute
compute time is still very high the wait
time has gone from almost zero to
something to something much higher and
what this means is is that the available
parallelism was higher than the
schedulable parallelism which means that
we had to wait before we could actually
schedule some of these so ways you could
you know avoid that would be buy more
slots you could run over smaller smaller
data sets or have queries that X or the
compute stages that that execute more
quickly so if we increase by another
order of magnitude 2 to 100 billion
dollar days 100 billion row data set we
can see that actually the compute time
has gone down to a very small amount and
almost the whole time we're waiting for
slots because we have we can see here
that we have 21,000 slots our 21,000 is
our available parallelism and these
numbers get a little bit important in a
second so it's the same query execution
it just means that we have a lot more a
lot more slots and we have the
introduction of this the scheduler
process and this scheduler is what
actually schedules different pieces of
execution to run on the different shards
ok so some background on bigquery slots
we get a lot of questions on on on slots
what they mean how to use them how many
you need
so the slot is a single unit of
scheduling it's you know it's hard to
say what it actually means in terms of
resources but it is some sort of
physical resources not all slots have
the same amount of resources so some can
have more Rams I'm gonna have more CPU
more i/o but you know you can sort of
thinking of it as a sort of one schedule
able unit of kind of parallel execution
these can be restarted by the scheduler
they can be cancelled so some queries in
a little bit that they can be cancelled
well the other key thing is it does
measure it's not a measure of
performance so some people say like well
I want more slots how do I get more
slots because I want my queries to run
faster well your queries are only gonna
run faster if you're exhausting the
available parallelism so you're just
getting more more throughput often that
translates into into faster queries but
but but not always so by default
everybody gets 2,000 slots
that's the amount of you know parallel
things you can you can run our scheduler
is
balances fairly between queries within a
project and then between projects
overall because this is a shared
multi-tenant system slots can be
scheduled individually for each each
stage of a query and I'm gonna show a
slot demo if I can wake my computer up
already so this is the Wikipedia
benchmark this is the 1 billion row data
set and you know running this query
should take about 6 seconds let's see
how long it takes today a 6 and a half
seconds and we can see that had 220 220
slots this is you know essentially the
same same thing that we saw earlier
here's the hundred 100 billion reel
query and this takes about 20 seconds to
run when we don't do anything else
and let's try running the 1 billion reel
query at the same time we're running the
100 billion reel query so what should
happen is the the the 1 billion row
query should still get 220 slots because
we have a fair scheduler that says you
know if we have two queries running each
one gets to use half the slots so the
this query should have run about as fast
as it did before and the other query
should run okay maybe a little bit
slower than before so this is even a
little bit slower it's about 20 seconds
now let's try running 200 billion rows
hundred billion row queries at the same
time and then you know we can throw in
our little small 1 billion row query as
well small 1 billion so if we think
about what should happen at when we do
this the the 1 billion row query should
still get 220 slots and then the two
larger ones should split the difference
so they should each get about 900 slots
and they should each take about 50
percent longer or about 30 seconds ok
this one took 25 seconds at 128 seconds
so we can kind of see how the the slot
scheduler works in in
in these query times and it generally
works works pretty well you can see you
know we spend a lot of time and in wait
time okay here we switch back to the
presentation please
to making research back not there we go
okay so that was sort of really simple
queries what if we want to do some more
interesting things and what can we know
about the bigquery architecture from
some of from other other queries so one
problem that that at least initial
versus the Dremel had were aggregation
with high cardinality so let's say you
wanted to do an aggregation where you
know in this case if there's lots of
distinct values of foo so what would
happen is the we would compute these
sort of partial partial counts in
parallel and then we would push those
back up to the two so the next the next
stage the one one problem is that we
can't actually remove any information
until until we've seen all of it so this
this the sort of master node has to have
to see in this case that even though
even though they only get five from Z
that that that they have to keep that
around until all the all the remaining
nodes have have completed and then only
finally after the after the the
lower-level nodes have completed can
they can they apply the limit so this
would often this would often overwhelm
this this master node so we don't do
that anymore we use we use shuffle in
the middle or in general we don't use
that anymore so if we have the same
input data we're going to apply another
step which which does a shuffle and so
what shuffle does is it says okay we're
gonna put all of the all of the things
that hash into this this this bucket
over here and pull it all the things
that hash into this bucket over here and
because we have all of the A's on the on
the one side and all of the Z's on the
other side we can sort of make logical
decisions about about those we can apply
the we can apply the limit at this node
before we before we then we send it up
to the to the master node so this makes
it scale a lot a lot more nicely so how
does this look in the
very plan so you know here's an example
using the same same dataset and a couple
of things too to call out so you can see
the shuffle here you can see that when
we do this aggregation we write to a
shuffle by hash so that's gonna hash
these into a number of different buckets
and then we can also see that this this
this number is not much higher this now
along is is no longer the the source
number of slots that we used this is the
number of shuffle sinks so this is the
number of how many places we we wrote
the the shuffle data to so just to go
back and and and and reiterate this you
know we can apply the partial group I at
the first level we do this sort of magic
shuffle we can do the remainder of the
group I sort it and and apply a limit
and and finally the final sort and final
limit sort of the merge sort and end
limit at the at the master node and this
slide just shows that you can we can
have any number of these shuffles so in
this in this query we're doing we're in
the inner query we're grouping by
language and title the outer query
recruiting improving by language so we
need to do two shuffles and that is
generally no problem so whenever stage n
doesn't know how many outputs it's going
to have we generally shuffle in between
its this is the one thing in the talk
that I can't talk about how it works but
it is very fast it's very magic it's it
is an in-memory shuffle and which also
means that there's a limited amount of
memory if you use too much just like
you're using too much on your local
machine you start paging and then and
then performance starts getting terrible
so often we get every once in a while we
get reports of somebody who's doing a
giant query it exhausts their shuffle
limit and all of a sudden their
performance goes down to goes from like
being being very fast to to much much
slower and then the shuffle quotas
are we have a default shuffle quota I
think of 2 2 terabytes and that sort of
the actual in-memory compressed data and
but that scales up for the number of
reserved slots that you have okay so you
know aggregations are simple this is all
relatively straightforward what if you
want to do a join so when you're joining
two large data sets we applied the same
trick we we use we use hash and shuffle
to to shuffle the left table and we
shuffle the right tables so that the
keys the matching keys end up in the
same spot and we can do a local a local
join in the query plan this looks like
this looks like this you can see that
we're right we're reading from each each
side of the of the join we are writing
it out to to the stage output and
shuffling by hash and and then here we
can see the the join kind of key words
are join each with each now used to be
that if you want to do a large join you
would have to like add the each keyword
which it was sort of non-standard and
not not great now we'll figure out if we
need to do in each join the alternative
okay and just as also see what we we had
to shuffle a large amount of data but
the in stage three we didn't have to
read all the rows because we were doing
a limit we were able to sort of cancel
cancel the rest of the shards because we
had already had had read enough data and
only had to read a million rows so if
you're doing a small join if you have a
small you know you're joining a large
table with a smaller table you don't
need to do this shuffle because that
would be really expensive to have to
move all of the data in both in both
tables to to each locations what you can
do is you basically call it a broadcast
join where the small table just gets
essentially sent to every single node
that's processing the larger
and then we can see this in the in the
query plan we have so we first we
shuffled the the left side of the table
sorry the right side of the table but
then we coalesced it down because like
because you know maybe we were reading
ten different shards we wanted to get it
into one one a single single shard we we
shuffled that down in this pad coalesce
and then we did in each with all so all
generally is a keyword that means we're
doing a broadcast join so it gets tricky
when you need to know like so say we're
doing is shuffle or we're doing a filter
it's hard to know how many how many
shards you're going to need in the
subsequent in the subsequent query
stages so what we do is we guess and
then if we guess wrong we we change it
so here we see in stage two we started
out with one shard that shard did you
know we needed more data and added
another shard and needed more data and
we added some more shards so this is
something that you'll see you'll see
very commonly we called it Auto awesome
but Auto awesome actually has several
different flavors this is just this is
just one of them and you can see here
sometimes in the query plans you'll see
these like shuffle repartition z' these
are essentially us just sort of
realizing that we have to add more add
more shards so something that people run
into as a problem sometimes is called a
skewed join now skew join is when one of
the keys that you're joining against has
a very large amount of data and it
generally also only happens when you
have sort of a high cardinality key that
also has you know a single one of those
keys has has a large proportion your
data so sometimes we see this in you
know somebody's doing a join on let's
say it's like product ID but half of
their product IDs or the empty string so
that they might have a million product
IDs
and that's what they really want to join
on but when they do this join the sort
of empty string makes it more difficult
to to schedule sure why in a second
but so I'm going to simulate this by
running a query where I just replaced
the every time the title has a C in it I
replace it with with just the string C
so this you know will be essentially
half of the data set and so this is what
the query plan ends up looking like it
so it still runs in general it still
runs but it takes a lot longer I think
this might have taken 20 minutes and
what you can see here is is this compute
time is is all the maximum time so the
Earth's IV this is all the long tail so
we don't even see the meet the medium
the the medium shards short times always
see or sort of the max max shard times
and that's one key to know that you're
seeing some sort of long tail or skew
effect to just sort of show what this
like on the architecture diagram we have
you know this one shard is getting a
large amount of data from from one side
and this char basically just has to
churn through all of this data it has to
do do a lot more work than the other
shards and we can't just apply the same
sort of reduce pet trick that we did for
the aggregations because we need to then
reshuffle both sides so this is
something that is slow right now it's
probably it's probable that we will we
will fix it in the in the future but you
know in case you run into this it's a
good good thing to know about another
problem that people hit a lot is they do
a large order by and they hit you know a
resources exceeded error so what
actually happens here so let's just walk
through an example as we were doing and
an order by foo we'd have a lot of
distinct values or a lot of values that
are read in parallel but in order to to
sort those
the masternode has to pass the process
somebody has to process all of these all
of these things in order to do this sort
and you know you can you can overload
the masternode and if we and you can
also run at a memory if there are if
there are too many too many things so
here's an example of a query plan that
actually hit this recently we added
support for returning query plans even
when even when queries fail
this can help you diagnose this kind of
problem but here you see stage 2 stage
two failed with with resources heaters
so you can kind of see and it failed on
filled on the sort so that's that's a
good indicator that that's what's what's
going on so what do you do when this
happens well you can add a limit so in
general if you're sorting a large amount
of data you don't really want you don't
really care about what happens in like
in Row 1 million to 1 you know you just
sort of you end up running that query
because that was sort of the the easy
thing which usually people are tend to
be care about are the things at the top
or the things at the bottom so in
general you can just add a limit and
this makes execution much easier because
we can do the partial sorts it at the
lower levels and we could we can drop
all over the all of the ones that exceed
the limit and so here we can see why
this is this is easier and this is what
the query plan for this looks like one
interesting thing to see is this this
output number this 220,000 does anybody
have an idea what this 220,000
represents so we saw that there were 220
Tortoni was the available parallelism
for this table and so the limit is a
thousand so basically each one of these
each one of these shards is producing a
thousand rows and and sending those to
the to the next level and yeah this
query probably it was
ran very fast just to sort of sum up
these some of these resources exceeded
problems you might run into there are
cases where the query fails and it
probably should fail so if you're
unintentionally trying to generate too
much data let's say you're using an Ag
string AG which you know basically takes
will concatenate a giant string with all
of the all of the values that you're the
aggregating now if you're doing that
with a billion different values we're
trying to create a single string that's
gonna be you know a terabyte long we're
gonna we're gonna fail also if you're
doing analytic functions which are
window functions and and you're not
using your forgets user partition by or
you're trying to sort of do like this
sort of a massive amount of data that
also can cause problems cross join is
also a killer if you have 202 million
row tables and you do a cross joint of
those you know how have a quadrillion
row table I'm sorry a trillion row table
but it's sort of it's it's easy to
generate sort of massive amounts of
intermediate data with a cross join and
those often will will fail so the
solution of these just sort of fix your
queries to not to not do that and then
there's also cases where you you
probably don't really need the results
which is the order by and to fix that
you can add a limit and then there's a
cases where you overload a shard like
the skewed join that I showed and the
solution is to split up your queries and
this is sort of tricky but you can
basically partition your query into two
pieces one is you run the high
cardinality part and filter out the one
that that over is it is overloaded and
the second one you run just on you run
just on that one and that should be a
much faster faster query then you have
to combine the results it's it's not
pleasant but it it works so not a little
bit of a digression on on how to count
things in in bigquery so there's really
three different
to to count things in in in bigquery one
is you can sort of do a user group I to
to come up with the to come up with
account this is you know kind of a pain
to write enquiries it's also also if
you're trying to try to count multiple
distinct things at the same time it can
be really difficult to to write the
queries but it's it's an exact and
reasonably scalable weight way to do it
the other way is count distinct one of
the things that people hated about the
bigquery legacy sequel was that count
distinct was approximate by default and
we have since fixed that in bigquery
standard sequel we have you know quite a
nice implementation of the of count
distinct but it is going to be
reasonably slow because shown a second
why counting distinct values is hard and
third we have approximate count distinct
which is it's very fast but it is an
approximation this is sort of a new
implementation that we've just added
that uses an algorithm called hyper log
log plus plus so hyper log log plus plus
is uses hyper log log which is a an
algorithm for for doing cardinality
estimation and hyper log log plus plus
is just sort of Google's version of that
that kind of applies using a lot of
experience in using this and it you know
tweaks it tweaks it a bit it has better
[Music]
better estimations that certain part and
cardinality ranges better accuracy and
uses less memory and is and it's faster
in general you don't have to know that
that's what that's what's being used
under the covers
you just get you know accurate count
distinct answers so these are some
benchmarks that I ran against our kind
of our our data set of various sizes and
we can see you know the error is is
staying under under 1% but the
the performance is much much faster and
these are log lines so it really is much
much faster on large large data sets so
we've also added some hyper log log
functions that kind of give you a little
more control over this this is kind of
geeky but I don't find it pretty
interesting so you know one of the
things that you know you might want to
do is you might want to sort of count
distinct users by by language from the
github data set in where language is the
the programming language so this takes
looks like 20 23 minutes to run because
you're running count distinct but really
you probably don't don't care about the
exact values so you can run if you use a
prop approximate distinct it'll run like
60 times faster so it's 20 to 22 seconds
instead but one of the issues with when
you're counting distinct values and this
doesn't units hold what holds whether
you're using an aprox count or an exact
count but if you try to take some
approximate counts and then sum those up
so if we wanted to get the sum of
distinct users per language and then
find the total number of distinct users
over all those numbers can't can't be
summed because like some of those same
users that we're using perl or also
using Ruby and it's hard to know what
those what those are so there are some
hyper log-log functions that lets you
kind of split up the process of of these
discounting into into different
different pieces and the the first one
is it builds a it builds a sketch a
sketch is sort of the kind of a
probabilistic mapping of the of the
values and the cardinality of the values
and so you can break it up into two
steps first you do the init which
creates the sketch the second you do the
extract and this actually will return
the same sorry the same value
ooh back the same value that that the
the other aprox count distinct returned
so you know why would you want to do
this well one one one option is you know
sometimes you have PII data and you want
to do aggregations but sometimes if you
do aggregations then you lose you lose
kind of that this distinct distinct this
you don't know how many kind of unique
users you have so this lets you save a
relatively small sketch and then finally
you can do the extract which which
computes the distinct values and then
but the nice thing about the kind of
cool thing about these sketches is you
can then you can combine the sketches so
if you do merge you can actually compute
the sum of multiple distinct RV of each
of each distinct sketch so you can come
up with the the total sum of all of all
distinct users per all distinct users in
in github and so the you know the the
overall number you get is the exact same
number is if you done the number aprox
can't distinct I'm just sort of
summarize these you know you can use
these hunan them to anonymize user IDs
you can use these so we have they're
sort of multiple hll functions we should
be releasing documentation on those
those shortly ok so go to another demo
and so now that i've shown like how to
how to do this in in general let's kind
of walk through a query that that is
slow and show how it would actually
optimize it in practice if i can type my
password in
okay okay so for this one I'm gonna use
one of my favorite tables here and this
is the deserve petabyte data set that we
that we that we built for DCP next last
year so this table is 11.1 petabytes
it's a trillion rows it's part of sort
of this retail data set that kind of
looks like a retail retail schema that
you might be you know used to seeing we
applied some kind of advanced bigquery
techniques to this that are best
practices so here instead of having a
sales table and an align item table we
have we basically do you normalize that
into a single row that has the sale and
the and the line item as sort of a
nested value so you can see how we have
this here we have the sale and then we
have each of the line items within
within that within that row but there's
still there's still a trillion outer
outer entries so the actually the inner
inner entries are probably something on
the order of 10 to 20 trillion okay so
here's the query that I want to run
hopefully that's a little bit legible
but I want to show that like yeah you
can do you can do complex queries and
you can you can go over data of this
size so one of the things we're
techniques for doing here is we're
looking at since this table is
partitioned we're gonna do a partition
filter so we're going to just do one
month of data we're also using a window
function so we're doing a partition in
order by to compute the running average
of sales for each product and
we are also yeah we're doing a join so
we're joining from the from this giant
table to our products table and you know
I didn't want to make you guys wait
while I ran this query but I ran it
right before and and it took two minutes
I wonder same thing years is you know it
only processed 1.8 or almost only
processed 2 terabytes so there's a
couple of reasons for that even though
it's a petabyte table you know one is we
only bill you for the the columns that
you read so we only had we only read a
few of the columns and second is we only
bill you for the partitions that you
read so we're only needed to read the
sort of one month's worth of worth of
partitions but there was still a lot of
a lot of data here and we did run a
regular expression over over a lot of
data so here's what the query plan looks
like so what do we see from this query
plan so we see that stage 1 is actually
where we spent all of our almost all of
our time and we notice that the output
rows were larger than the input rows and
so that seems a little bit funny but one
of the things that we had to do here in
this in this query is we've we ended up
flattening the these line items so for
each of the each of the line items had
to be sort of had to be unnecessary
partition stages and if you look at that
then yes that's what they are this other
one that looks like this this stage that
process 10 10 billion rows that's an
interesting one so we look in here
and it's we can see that we did in each
all join so we did a broadcast join so
that's that's that's positive news we
know that we didn't have to shuffle we
didn't have to shuffle actually these
these 10 billion rows because that would
have been
expensive or did we actually we did so
that say that was that was that was
expensive but so what what are we like
so let's look at the this stage where we
read so this is the stage where we read
the products table and so the products
table had 2 million 2 million products
and we've we filtered it down to 2 to
600 projects which is why we could do
the broadcast but actually it only
started out as 2 million products so one
of the things we could do is so we're
doing applying this filter here we're
filtering on the and this is actually
one one nice thing in in standard sequel
is we actually have an optimizer we can
push this filter inside the in inside
the join but we're filtering on on the
key wallets and products if we change
this to filter the key while it's in the
in the sales table will end up having
you know we can we can push this all the
way into the into the stores layer we
can end up having to read read out a lot
less data and hopefully this query
should go should go faster so let's see
let's see how long this takes
come on come on bigquery so 30 seconds
so that's a lot a lot faster factor of
six to give us the same answer now
notice one other option we could have
had was two we could have run it on a
smaller smaller set of partitions but
you know we're doing we want to do the
trailing weekly average and so if you do
it a lot
less than a month then that's gonna you
know you may not it may not get the the
type of answers that you want so here we
see that the big difference is in this
first stage where you know we still had
to read the underlying seven billion
rows but we only render output four
billion and we can see that this this
filter this regular expression was was
was pushed down into into this layer
here and can we switch back the
presentation
okay so that's all I have
there's some other if you like bigquery
there's some other other presentations
you might be interested in there was a
data model you know obviously these have
already already passed but they will be
online so that you can you can stream
them at your at your leisure but thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]